pinballs its way into the Dallas Zone hacket
paw on Dan for and a shot by carali juggled off
the chest of oer he'll punch it to the corner
check throwing there as the Stars bring it to
neutralized Robertson he's got help of cutting
Harley Robertson Harley he [Applause] scores
all it took was 27 seconds Thomas Harley gets the
Stars off and running fourth line and third pair
on defense and the stars go with the top Trio
up front and a defenseman the weak side d man
always joins out of the zone for the Stars a sweet
Sumptuous little saucer pass by Robertson right on
the tape Harley cruises in takes his move back to
The Far Side Jake Bean awaits it and then turned
over duan's got space duchan in save vers leein
still looking for his first with the Stars he has
had some Dynamite looks including that one he's
had a couple where he's been in behind everybody
like that good work by Mason marshman to force the
turnover carried in singer poked off of his stick
a battle of number fours headed right back singer
hang it up in front it trickles in in front it was
Dimitri baronov if went off the big man it's
his third NHL game it would be his first NHL
goal but Columbus has an equalizer tart stop by
murans and then the guy who's built like a bomb
shelter just nudges his way to the front of the
net against pavelski and it just carams its way
and you're not going to get a more ugly goal than
that one that's like the the brotherly push with
the Eagles almost we'll see a little overow ice
here perhaps Carter sandl working the game with
Gord DWI they've been busy both teams on the
board four on four for 100 seconds it's van
Tilly to the left side shot score it trickled
through the jackets are looking to discuss who
touched it but the blast from the left wing circle
from serson well this is a nice little dangle by
fantelli just pulls it into his skates a little
bit to get it across and the one-time by severon
It Was a Rolling Puck and he didn't know where
it was going and neither did Jake ainger who
did didn't get himself fully across and square
I mean that thing's just bouncing he gets it on
the [Applause] skip averaging just shy of 20
minutes per game on the season third most on
the team just behind as andell and of course hero
Hainan leads the way about five 6 minutes clear of
anyone else in the pack have not been rewarded
but they've had multiple scoring chances some
tired jackets as the Stars Top Line controls off
the face off lung Quist up high Robertson shot
score hits was going through the slot redirected
and the stars all that pressure pays off they've
tied the game at two change when you ice the pck
it can't be a diffuser Tire guys out there the
stars are clobbering them on the faceof dots and
they get two to the net after winning the draw
hence wins the draw both pavelski and rope go to
that low slot area a rough shift all around for
wenky who turned the puck over earlier this time
doesn't get under the stick or and the length of
good Branson the other d man out there what
a terrific exit by the stars out of Their Own
Zone they're back in once again left for Marchman
now D Shane behind the net drops in front Marchman
scores they're just driving the play to the
Blue Jackets here in the second period and
this line has spearheaded it I mean just toss
it into the fond deot in front of the net and
go there little exchange little flipper Drive
in the youngster Fen Tilly in front of the net
doesn't eliminate nobody does and Mason Marchman
is able to waft in there and Tuck one through
crossovers it's it's man it's I hate this is
why I hate this rule it's frame by frame it's
got nothing to do with anything really and the
irony again is that it was douching egregiously
offside the C video review determined that the
play was offside we have no goal please reset
third period about to begin and it's the
Stars Top Line they begin all three periods
they scored the game's first goal 27 seconds in
left side suor with a blast save rebound scored
Matt [Applause] Duan it was only a matter a
time Tyler San grabs the puck it's his first
with the Stars how fitting that it comes from a
face off this time on the right side it's Tyler
San that wins it clean back they go to work off
that the initial shot Ricochet off of marchment
and then an aggressive Ryan suder comes down the
left side grabs the rebound pounds it off of Mur
lein can't control it it it's a rising blast
off his shoulder and a corpulent rebound for
duchaine to bounce upon Janes got a three- game
point streak working here as well all alone it's
jender back hit save left hand Oger somehow
stayed with what a save the save of the night
this has happened a couple of times to hackin
paaw and Harley as a defending pair they're
both over on the wall nobody's in behind other
than Boon Jenner in tight and as he goes to the
back and this is just absolute Larsen it's too
bad he couldn't get it in the reticulate take
it away Ben gets to the loose Puck checks
the mirror sees he's got time lifts it out
to the Columbus Blue Line juggling Johnston
right side shot scor to [Music] [Applause]
donov and gny toov goes high on M leans there's
the insurance tally and it's four two Dallas
you give up by defenseman that you might need
some Sav after it wensky just ginu knife the
puck lost his stick didn't get contact when he
tried to do that and ultimately a Rolling Puck
gets slung short Side by dadonov Perfect shot
rosik down the right wing side he'll leave it
side of the net turnaround shot Jenner Ander
the save Ben and it's handed off to dunov he's
got Johnston in all alone for the empty net
Wyatt Johnston becomes the fifth different
star to score 52 Dallas and they are on their
way with a couple of chances for them in the
third period but AER better and nice boy they
played really well with one another as lines
in the game tonight even that you know all
three guys in support of one and the Ali and
Jun as it's moved to the far side and now Olivier
pause it up the wall shot blasted wide rebound
score carali it was a hot rebound off the proov
blast it bounced perfectly to carali well it's
the elasticity nature of the end boards that
thing tickled twine wide of the net and came
off perfectly to carali on the other side and
I mean like a hot pass sometimes it hits that
that Dasher the yellow Dasher at the bottom
and it's harder down there rossik curls in
the corner once again goodro sharp angle his
bid gets blocked one more wide from Jenner the
horn sounds and the stars on the strength of
a big third period beat the Blue Jackets 5-3